- Dans un petit boisé
d'Hochelaga, un regroupement
de citoyens qui s'inquiètent
de leur futur voisin.
ELIZABETH GREENE, Mobilisation
6600 Parc-Nature MHM
- Ceux qui peuvent partir de là,
ceux qui ont les moyens vont
quitter. Mais ceux qui peuvent
pas, les plus démunis vont
rester là. Puis qu'est-ce
que ça va faire? Ça va
faire un ghetto, t'sais.
- Cette résidente du secteur,
au coeur de la mobilisation,
a pris le pouls du voisinage.
CASSANDRE CHARBONNEAU-JOBIN,
Mobilisation 6600 Parc-Nature
- Ils nous parlent de
deux choses : d'espaces verts
et de logement. De logements
abordables. Personne nous dit :
ça manque de conteneurs
dans le quartier, ça manque de
camions. Personne nous dit ça.
- Ray-Mont Logistiques a acheté
ce terrain contaminé en 2016
pour 20 millions de dollars.
La plateforme de transbordement
qu'il veut construire
pourra accueillir environ
10 000 conteneurs et être
en activité 24 heures sur 24.
CHARLES RAYMOND,
PDG, Ray-Mont Logistiques
- On reçoit des wagons,
on reçoit leurs marchandises
et on transfère dans des
conteneurs. Les conteneurs
transitent de chez nous pour
aller au port. Puis, les ports
bougent dans le reste du monde,
dans 150 pays.
- Après avoir refusé de délivrer
le permis de construire,
Montréal a été contrainte
de le faire par deux décisions
rendues par les tribunaux.
L'entreprise poursuit
aujourd'hui la Ville
pour 373 millions de dollars.
- On est un citoyen corporatif
et, comme tout citoyen...
qui ont subi des dommages
pendant quatre ans parce que
la Ville a agi illégalement,
on considère qu'on a le droit
à un dédommagement. Par contre,
on n'est pas fermés à discuter.
- Un groupe de travail sur
les mesures d'atténuation
doit faire ses propositions
d'ici fin septembre.
Il réunit des citoyens,
des représentants de la Ville
et de l'entreprise.
Ce matin-là, ils découvrent
les installations actuelles
de Ray-Mont, dans le sud-ouest
de la Ville. Visite guidée
par le PDG de l'entreprise.
ANAÏS HOUDE, citoyenne et
membre du groupe de travail
- C'est un site industriel
horrible parmi tant d'autres,
là! On est loin de...
de la friche de Viauville!
- Une semaine plus tard,
c'est justement le quartier
de Viauville que le groupe
arpente pour jauger
les impacts potentiels.
Ray-Mont a elle-même listé
les nuisances potentielles
de sa plateforme, qe ce soit
les îlots de chaleur,
le bruit et les vibrations
ou encore la vermine.
Dans Pointe-Saint-Charles,
un talus planté d'arbres
sépare une partie du site
des résidences en face.
L'idée d'une zone tampon est
aussi avancée dans Hochelaga.
Cela pourrait être porté
par le ministère fédéral
des Transports.
CATHERYN ROY-GOYETTE,
candidate, NPD Hochelaga, Qc
- Qui saisira la gare de triage
du CN dans laquelle on se trouve
en ce moment pour la céder
à la Ville de Montréal
et ainsi créer un immense
lien... lien vert qui reliera
Notre-Dame au parc Maisonneuve,
qui pourra être reboisé,
revégétalisé et servir
aux citoyens.
- Les deux autres candidats
aux élections fédérales,
la libérale Soraya Martinez
et le bloquiste Simon Marchand,
sont d'accord avec cette idée
de parc linéaire.
Les citoyens, eux, s'inquiètent
des travaux en cours, qui
ne devraient concerner que
la réhabilitation du terrain.
Le ministère de l'Environnement
a envoyé des inspecteurs et
assure que tout est conforme
aux autorisations.
RICHARD CAMPEAU, adj. parlem.
du ministre de l'Environnement
- Notre seul espoir est
politique puis il faut
jamais sous-estimer la force
d'une grogne citoyenne.
Ça fait cinq ans qu'il a
des problèmes avec son projet.
S'il débute, il va continuer
à avoir des problèmes,
ça, je vous le garantis.
- Et ils réclament des études
d'impact environnemental,
mais aussi que le projet soit
soumis au Bureau d'audience
publique sur l'environnement.
Sauf que...
- Il y a pas de projet,
actuellement, on sait pas
de quoi aura l'air le projet.
Alors, comme on sait pas
de quoi aura l'air le projet,
on peut pas faire d'étude
environnementale pour le moment,
c'est tout... question
de processus à respecter.
- Et ce dossier ne manquera
pas d'animer la campagne
électorale municipale.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat
à la mairie de Montréal
- Je pense qu'il faut faire
une pause, il faut qu'on se
parle. Mais ça prend des gens
qui seront crédibles pour
s'occuper de ce dossier-là.
Il est en plein droit. Euh...
est-ce qu'on veut exproprier ça?
Peut-être. Nous, on était prêts,
même, à acheter le terrain,
à l'époque.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- On ne va pas s'excuser
de souhaiter qu'il y ait
du développement économique
le plus vert possible et qui
s'inscrit dans une logique ou
dans un développement durable,
intéressant, surtout quand c'est
en plein milieu d'un quartier.
- Et il faudra aussi composer
avec un autre joueur qui va
passer le long du terrain :
le REM de l'Est.
En attendant, l'aménagement
se poursuit sur le site,
bientôt l'étape de l'asphaltage.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, M